In Jama
tells us
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us the most beloved prayer to
Allah
is the prayer of
on the day of J in j
I know many of us go to work around
this time if you're working in the
morning we need to figure out ways to
work especially
into our routines it will enhance our
lives it will enhance our religion and
it will enhance our relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala most
importantly
and so
on is the best place to start. This is
why the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
said this to teach us where to start and
especially
our children especially young men. This
masid should be busting at the seams
with young men here at the break of dawn
making salah
making their ancestors their forefathers
proud
pleasing Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Any
of us have children boys over the age of
8 n 10 years old we need to roll them
out of bed and get them into the masjid.
This is the next generation.
When a person grows up doing something,
they usually grow old doing it.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
So
this is an incredibly
important narration,
but it's a narration
It's a statement of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam that is taken
directly from the Quran. When we look at
the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
sunnah
and we match it up with the Quran.
We see that the relationship that the
sunnah
has with the Quran
is in one of three ways always. There is
no fourth to these three things.
So if we say what is the relationship
between the Quran and the prophet Sunnah
we say that relationship
is in one of three ways or all of those
three ways sometimes.
no fourth these are the only three
ways that the sunnah
has a relationship to the Quran.
Number one, Allah says something in the
Quran and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam repeats it as it is. He does
not add to it. He does not detail it. It
is kept as it is. But the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam says it in
different words.
The second
is that it is in the Quran and the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
expounds upon it. So it's in the Quran
generally it's mentioned it's alluded to
it's gestured to and the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam
expounds upon it.
The third is that it is not in the
Quran.
It's not in the Quran at all and the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
mentions it and it's only found in the
sunnah. Do we have examples of this? For
instance, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
[Silence]
let's try it again.
Say it.
And our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
saysith.
So here we have the exact same thing
being repeated in the Quran and in the
Sunnah. The second something is
mentioned generally in the Quran but it
is
expounded upon and detailed in the
Sunnah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
the thief whether he be male or female
you are commanded to cut their hand off
their hands.
Now if we took the the verse alone as it
is, it would mean we would cut both
their hands off from the shoulder.
However, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam expounds upon this verse
and he shows us that the cutting is from
the wrist. It's never above the wrist.
Number two, it is with the right hand.
Number three, there is no cutting of the
hand in anything that is stolen from a
place that is not safeguarded
or the item has to be worth more than a
fourth of a gold coin of a din.
These are things that are not found in
the Quran. They are detailed in the
Sunnah.
The third, a ruling that is in the
Sunnah. It is not in the Quran anywhere.
It's nowhere in the Quran.
Who can give us an example of this?
A rajim is a good example. It was in the
Quran and then it was later abregated.
But let's go for something that was
never a verse of the Quran.
Something that every one of us practices
and we know it to be
the ruling of the Quran and Sunnah
and it is something which
none of us has ever done. I could
probably swear right now between
thea at thea between
that none of us here in this room has
ever done it and I'd probably be right
for instance there's many examples but
the one I have in mind for instance the
one that the prophet himself gave saiam
he tells us at
no man is to ever try or attempt to
separate between the Quran and Sunnah.
Verily, there are things that I have
brought in the Sunnah that are not in
the Quran. And then he gives an example.
He says, I have prohibited the eating of
domestic donkey. Has any of us here ever
eaten domestic donkey?
Domesticated donkey meat. Any of us? No.
We have not. Even if we went to live
with the aboriges in Australia, we
probably would not have eaten
domesticated donkey meat.
He says, "And that is not in the Quran."
What about the permissibility of eating
zebras? Is that permissible? Yes. Is
that in the Quran? No. What about the
permissibility of eating horse meat? Is
that in the Quran?
Horse meat? Yeah. idea when we have a
famine one day, you're going to look at
that horse a cheeseburger dripping
with with all the sauces, right?
The point is is that there are many
rulings in the Sunnah that are now found
in the Quran. Those are the three
relationships shared by the Quran and
Sunnah.
Number one, it is what?
You said what? Echo. Echoing an
echo.
That's good. Yes, that's a very good
wording.
He says, see, you're you're pretty
pretty smart guy, mashallah.
yes, to echo what is already in the
Quran. Number two,
number two is what? From over here.
is to expound upon something. Or it
could be the opposite. It could be that
it's in the Quran mentioned very general
and the prophet makes it specific like
we we just heard with respect to
the penalty of theft. Right? The Quran
makes it very general but the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam specifies it.
Right? And the third is that there is
something in the sunnah that is not
found in the Quran at all. And this is
why it is so dangerous to attempt to
understand the Quran without
deep
intimate knowledge of the sunnah of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
because what he says
is a derivative of the Quran and it is
an addition to the Quran and it is an
echo of the Quran.
An example of this is the narration of
anis. You may say for instance what does
this have to do with the narration of
anis at hand? Annis narrates that the
messenger of Allah sallall.aii Wasallam
said, "Whoever goes out to seek
knowledge, we already know what
knowledge is, right?"
Okay? Whoever goes out and embarks on a
journey to seek knowledge, then this
person is considered to be on a path
meaning they are in jihad
until they return to their home. And so
in this narration we have knowledge
being a type of jihad. Is this found in
the Quran?
Is it in the Quran?
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us,
"Oh prophet, fight against the
disbelievers. ers and the hypocrites.
How do we fight? How is the fight
against the disbelievers? A physical
one. And the fight against h the hipp h
the hypocrites and hypocrisy. Is it a
physical one or an intellectual one? A
knowledge a knowledge fight.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "And it
is not possible or probable that every
single person will be able to go out in
to battle."
So we you are to designate a group from
amongst every people, every community
that will seek knowledge to hold that.
And so here we have those who go to
fight and those who stay to fight the
intellectual knowledgebased
fight. For this reason, the scholars
agree
that the student of knowledge and the
scholar are to be paid from zakah.
Even if they're wealthy, they are to be
given regular payment from zak from
regular payment from zaka even if
they're wealthy as payment just a
soldier or a
you know a knight or a soldier or an
archer or a general. They are paid when
they go out to fight even if they're
wealthy. This is not to take them out of
poverty or to help them. This is
their right. They earned this from
[Arabic recitation]